why is the rum
always gone
oh that's why
captain jack sparrow of the pirates of
the caribbean movies was known to enjoy
a few sips
of rum and he's not the only one today
the spirit accounts for
2.3 billion dollars in revenue here in
the united states
captain morgan and bacardi are two of
the five best-selling spirit brands of
any kind
recently sales of value rums are down
but
super premium rums are surging one of
those the real mccoy
borrows from the past to separate itself
from that
stiff competition
most people have never really had an
opportunity to taste
completely unadulterated rums as the
founder and ceo of real mccoy rum
bailey pryor is trying to change that
you have all the same traditions and
techniques that you would have in the
finest scotch whiskies the finest cognac
so i can sip rum on the rocks yup neat
on the rocks it's beautiful we can do a
little tasting if you'd like without a
doubt
the mystic connecticut based prior has a
small test distillery
where he can develop new products or
expressions he poured us three now next
we're going to go to the five year
you're going to start getting more of
the barrel in this now you're going to
start to get the lignans and tannins
from the wood so go ahead and give that
a little sip
i'm really amazed at how smooth these
are
that's what people tell me all the time
they say i had no idea rum could taste
like
i had no idea rum could taste like this
prior had
no experience making rum when he created
the real mccoy
he spent decades working in film first
as a production assistant on movies like
mystic pizza and home alone
then making documentaries i do all my
own research and i write all my own
scripts i direct my documentary films
and so
i just get fascinated with subjects and
then i'll go all the way down the rabbit
hole
never more so than with his film about
the legendary rum runner
bill mccoy he's really the only name you
know from the prohibition era who wasn't
a psychopathic murderer
right there's al capone baby face nelson
a machine gun kelly and
the guy who refused to break the law
bill mccoy or rip off his customers
like the world around him bill mccoy's
life was about to turn
upside down pryor's 2012 film
explored how the former shipbuilder
helped create the illicit alcohol trade
up and down the east coast after
ratification of the 18th amendment
he was the first guy to fill up a boat
full of rum in january of 1920 down in
the caribbean he sailed it up to new
york city and acted as a floating liquor
store
three miles offshore a loophole in u.s
law
made that international waters allowing
mccoy to supply
smaller boats which would bring his rum
back to shore
the government had good reason to
silence his legend
he became the face of rum row other
people would cut their alcohols with
turpentine wood alcohol prune juice
water mccoy never did that so they
called his product the real mccoy
and i just thought you know that phrase
it's such a household name i wonder if
anyone's ever trademarked it
turns out no one had so pryor did
then using photographs he traced mccoy's
rum through the tax stamps on its
barrels
to barbados barbados is the birthplace
of rum
so the tradition of rum producing goes
back about 400 years in barbados
pryor and his wife jennifer headed down
to the caribbean island in search of the
distillery that produced mccoy's barrels
they ended up at four square distillery
home to fourth generation rum maker
richard seal so we don't know if that's
where it came from or not
but i asked richard if he would be
willing to work with us and i said i
wanted the kind of rum that would have
been on mccoy's ship
back in 1920 so when someone takes a sip
of this they can taste what tradition is
all about
taste the real mccoy they can taste the
real mccoy and he said well that's all
we make
and that's what started the whole thing
one of the last family-owned
distilleries on barbados
foursquare combines the past with the
present in brewing
the key component to rum sugarcane is
grown on the property
it's turned into molasses and distilled
in a traditional pot still
which slows down the process but adds
more flavor to the rum
everything is done in a sustainable
process as you can possibly do on an
island we're 100 produced in barbados so
we even do the bottling down there
please tell me you are not going three
miles out in the water to pick up the
shipments as they come in the same way
we've talked about having a party out
there pryor says they're now selling up
to 18 000
cases of rum a year after just 1500 in
year one
2013.
he travels to rum festivals around the
world
educating people on how rum should taste
and pryor is so confident that his rum
really is the
real mccoy he lobbied the u.s government
to become the first spirit company to
list its ingredients
on the label i'm convinced that people
today
want to be informed they want
transparency people want to drink less
typically now but they want to drink
better and bill mccoy became an iconic
moral barometer
as complex and controversial as the era
itself
to think back this documentary sort of
started
all of this would you ever have imagined
at the beginning of that that this is
where you'd be
no uh in fact it was sort of a lark you
know we're like hey this is fun we'll
just do this on the side you know
sell to our friends or something like
that and and then it just kind of took
off
i lift a glass to you and say cheers
cheers just thank you jesus
cheers cheers
so as promised
you guys can taste this is the 12. i'm
telling you all three to me we're so
smooth in comparison to other spirits
that i've tasted
you've got the 12 to five and i just
love the smell of it
it's just have a sip just have a so
aromatic there's there's something just
sugary syrupy goodness that you it's
molasses you're right it is it's good
it's very smooth it's very nice not what
you expect from rum
no not always especially when it's aged
12 years i mean that's like
it's delicious